hierauf diesem gartengrundstück im
sächsischen hochkirch baut gabriele
kurze ihr neues wohnhaus am mittwoch
klingelt plötzlich ihr telefon
wir bekamen plötzlich den anruf von
baggerfahrer es wurde ein knochen und
eine tonscherbe finden auch einen
menschen schädel hat der baggerfahrer in
der schaufel gabriele kurze geht von
einem verbrechen aus und alarmiert
sofort die polizei als nächstes kamen
die polizisten die hier ausgegraben
haben dieses ganze skelette es war sehr
gut zu sehen insgesamt
und dann kam nach und nach in dem
bereich weitere skelette zu tage wie man
in das erdreich kam waren knochen zu
sehen
archäologen werden dazu geholt und es
stellt sich heraus die knochen stammen
aus dem siebenjährigen krieg sind also
262 jahre alt 1758 fand ihr ein blutiges
gemetzel stadt 9000 preußen und 8000
österreicher starben
die toten wurden in massengräber
geworfen und mit kalk gestreut
wir leben hier und hochkirch mit der
geschichte aber es ist schon ein
merkwürdiges gefühl und man will sich
nicht in einzelheiten reinsteigern jeder
krieg insgesamt finden die archäologen
34 skelette in gabriele kurzes garten
und eine kanonenkugel sowie verrostete
uniform knöpfe fürs museum ist das zu
wenig die knochen werden in müllsäcke
gelegt und im schuppen gestapelt der
evangelische ortspfarrer will sie bald
beerdigen